beautiful skies out there lots of blue  sky just giving you a heads up if we can  keep the skies clear enough for the peak  of the leonids meteor shower this week  that's the night of november 17th going  into the morning of the thursday morning  overnight so that night it looks like we  may  get rid of a lot of the clouds from  wednesday into thursday more clouds  clouds coming in tonight tomorrow and  then again on friday but this may be  just the perfect window to see these  we will have a building fuller waxing  moon so the moonlight is going to  interfere a little bit but 10 to 15  shooting stars per hour so if you can  get away from the bright city lights you  may be able to see some of those  shooting stars